hey good to see you again today if you
were here obviously for a good morning
mug club this morning if you're not
seeing you is all right of course it is
mug club quarantine month where we are
doing two shows Monday Wednesday Friday
we're doing good morning Mon Club we're
offering everything for free in front of
the paywall so what you're about to
watch is Ash Wednesday a little more
casual or you guys send in your
questions your topics we talk about them
not necessarily political the promo code
is quarantine if you enter that and you
get $30 off so that after this month you
can still see all this content at la
doors credit coms / mud club that's
quarantine $30 off it's our way of
giving back to you because we can't sing
or dance and none of us can separate
conjoined twins so in a medical pandemic
I don't know of how much use to you I am
beyond jokes but I hope that you enjoy
this program and we'll see you tomorrow
with a live stream
[Music]
yeah wow that's a those are some sensual
noises yes there but when Ash Wednesday
how do you know it's ash wednesday
because I'm wearing this shirt no we we
fix the situation I can only wear this
shirt on Wednesday because the red is
too bright yeah I ever lights on the
Angela's it's vibrant it is what I'm
like I'm not very vibrant right now
because I went to sleep very late by the
way we have a quarterback Garrett Gerald
a half asian bill and reg the beast why
why wrench how did you come to exist how
did I come to exist on the show on the
show I think Stephen noticed me under
one of my many pseudonyms on Twitter
arguing with someone is that you
messaged me a story you so you can yeah
I was I was arguing with someone about
abortion in your the comments to one of
your tweets and I was just a fan and you
messaged me and said hello senior you
seem like a smart fellow and I said oh
thanks and we chatted a tiny bit I
started sending you articles and stuff
that I've written on medium right and
then we connected we really bonded over
the salon pedophile yes our mutual
hatred for pedophiles I think I think
that was what actually started brothers
and auntie pederast arms
there was a reason to bond people
together just like marx and engels the
Spock
to my Kirk if I were a Kirk but I'm not
he's a Spock to my guy with a big head
Worf Worf yeah but that guy yeah that
guy gets the that guy gets laid oh it's
true I don't remember this about about
reg exactly but I must have noticed just
how how sharp he was and then the soap I
didn't know at the time that you were
sending articles to everybody during
during the election he just like to be a
disrupter he was working at a like
college and then I turned out he was
just sending stuff out to people who he
thought could get the message out it was
small
just to try and cause chaos yeah the me
more was a 2016 many many accounts and
many avenues but this was this was the
one that really worked this was a yeah
well who don't know by the way you can
send in your video questions I think we
have one today a telecom slash ask but
tell them about the salon pedophile for
people who don't remember because I
remember you sent it to me and I thought
well so I'm gonna salon there they said
pedophile right you know no surprise
right yeah so the Todd Nickerson they
wrote this puff piece about a pedophile
called Todd Nickerson her name Todd
Nickerson rather and but his whole Janek
was I am a minor attracted person but I
would never ever act on it right right
and so so it was called like the
virtuous pedophile or whatever so I
think it was called a pedophile but not
a monster there were actually a lot of
articles around that time yeah there was
a really strong movement yeah yeah I
ended up digging he was on these message
boards and gotta hand it to him he used
his real name several times on message
boards and it was some of the beta forum
where you would you know talk about
really edgy things like pedophilia or
why would you have to hand it to him I'm
just saying I was like Bernie on China
poverty look for something in his
opponent to respect kids the you just
own name this guy he's walking on two
legs
yeah so at the feet on these debate
boards he actually said that if society
ever became more accepting and more
sex-positive he would engage in sex play
with the child he said I'll never
apologize for that so his his whole base
was saying that you know I would never
act on it actually he had sort of
committed to exactly it wasn't he
talking about in the message boards
grooming and all the time yeah it seems
like he was actively grooming someone
yeah yeah definitely and and last I
checked he was he's like 40-something
and he was with some girl who's like
just turned 18 well you know I don't
baby steps ah he's not babies he's
already gonna try baby steps
newly adult steps he yeah and then he
wrote like three more articles we did
this whole article and what I wrote was
hey there's a certain point where I'm no
longer I guess I'm no longer
prioritizing empathy yeah
our priority is the children the most
vulnerable among us just imagine right
now who is a coronavirus and someone's
like but you know what I really I really
like coughing on old people yeah
understands like know at a certain point
you're not allowed in the village right
and so for me I think I even know what I
said you get your help we hope that you
get your help but you can't be in the
village these are the boundaries if you
try to re-enter you get a bullet in the
head yeah exactly and then he wrote he
had the gall to write an article my was
it my week or my Monday in the
right-wing hates fear what cosmic bunny
hole did I did a currently active
pedophile right gets to call me a
monster was the salon what I find most
interesting about that is that it by him
you know cut by implication it's that
that there's some kind of left-wing
sphere where he's celebrated and that
he's a hero but if he goes into this
other world called you know being a
moral person why does everything have to
be left and right with you and why hatin
Pettit I hate pedophiles you right-wing
bigoted well very well that's now you've
drawn the lines yeah and I was actually
willing to draw it before
pedophilia no well then this was right
on the heels of everybody on the
conservative side being called you know
stupid or like oh that's a conspiracy
theory thinking that normalizing
pedophilia was kind of that next step
right you know some people you know
wrongly brought it up in some cases but
in other case we're like well what is
next like if you guys continue down this
line of crazy like what's gonna happen
and by you guys I mean particularly
folks in the medium well we don't we see
now coming from Hollywood reason people
like Polanski potentially Harvey
Weinstein people like Kevin Spacey you
see Corey Haim Corey Feldman these
people all coming out talking about how
it's one of the the biggest open secrets
in Hollywood and these are the people
who are sort of at the forefront of
spearheading change and of course Salon
is very Hollywood friendly they get all
kinds of puff pieces and so
every should speak to them there which
is amazing to me we go all hustling
these people don't seem have a problem
with it these people meaning people in
the entertainment industry we could see
it coming coming down the pike and then
I think that we're all removed weren't
they retch yeah eventually salon remove
the articles it was like just an
advertiser thing I became uncomfortable
yeah it is comparable if they wanted to
pull ads from a website that supported
pedophilia not one but three times and
advertise on YouTube wanted to pull
because I called someone Mexican so it's
true yeah I mean those are not roughly
equivalent nevermind that's that was the
sermonette joke it was sarcasm there I
was trying to play off you know I made
the worst decision or the dream whatever
on a virus
I was with Johnny boy you know you know
I hadn't eaten I get nervous and I can't
eat before live shows and so afterwards
I you know I'm kind of hungry you know
let me see what they have a quick trip
and I got whoa no nose on the hot
rollers no to the sneeze guard well to
be fair I took extra precautions I asked
him I said okay which one of these have
been put out most recently because I was
late at night after the stream and I
picked the one that was farthest in so
the sneeze guard to do most of it
Sully's guardian oh the one that was
placed two days ago pretty good about it
because they move a lot of quick trip
you ever had they're there but continues
oh gosh they're not good for you but
they taste they're delicious
I don't even eat fast food but those are
the things that I can't I mean you know
that's not faster that's fastest food
it's just from rollers to mouth you
might as order a side of dysentery yeah
basically and well you know I'm fine I
feel great
Wow now really I feel tired today but I
feel you know my intestines I feel like
a million bucks a little bit just to
block me up we'll check back just in a
few days there's cheese and processed
whatever that layer is it's not bread I
don't know what uh whatever it is it's
just it's like wax paper was it tasty I
think oh my god was it tasty I mean yes
I know
that's a problem I love [ __ ] quick hoop
is my favorite place in the world on set
of home Hey are you surprised that wine
over there doesn't eat taquitos I do eat
taquitos just not from a quick trip
typically I don't even know if they're
taquitos honestly is it like in
parentheses right it's not even a real
right you know it's a techie actually I
don't think I get that taquitos I get
the buffalo chicken if anyone out there
who goes to Kwik Trip you know I'm
talking about it's just like it's it's
it's just like a taste cuz it's a tube
of the chicken and cheese yeah are just
one in the same oh wow they just sort of
meld it together into this very thick
very clogging piece well roll of heaven
oh nice there's nothing there's nothing
good about it I guessed wrong I said
jack-in-the-box um you said you made a
bad eating this says jack-in-the-box
would have been a far superior it's Jack
about to be child's play compared to a
taquito on a roller
I thought you say you're gonna go to the
hello guys got some of that hot sauce
everyone knows the halal guys don't
they're good yes I used to do whole all
guys all the time until I just realize
my my mouth is used to spice but your
stomach can't take it
Oh guys and it tastes so good it was
burning a hole oh my gosh yeah it tastes
so good but the neck I don't mean it's
not the kind of thing where you just go
to the bathroom like it's like like your
when you like people can see you never
walk the halal walk so yeah reg came to
us there and then you were worked
part-time for us yeah and then you uh
you I don't want to review but you you
worked yourself out of a job yeah yeah
basically I was in yeah teaching he was
a professor and I said put all your put
all your lessons on tape yeah and
shifted to a more online formats right
yeah laser disc what would be what would
they have done if you said no I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna record this what
they've just brought in someone else
yeah probably
oh so then he calls me he's like I need
to talk about something he's all nervous
I'm thinking oh no I'm gonna lose reg
tenure right and then they were like hey
we're firing you and I said
but inside of it and then I gave him a
raise and he came to work for us full
time and you know I'll just thank God
he's on our side
what's your squat 637 what's the odd
number that I yeah how did you get the
37 one pound
collars weighted collars oh you get
those really beefy within powerlifting
metal ones that you bolt on yeah but I
like using those you know the plastic
ones are nice but I dumped quite a few
squats cuz I would work without a
spotter so okay well it can end up
someone very smart it sounds like you
engage in some stupidly risky behavior
no no not really if you got the power
rack there get your course and because
you are willing to dump it then then
you're pretty safe yeah you know usually
pretty safe a lot of people unless if
you don't have the power rack there if
you just dump a squat and go in the
dangerous thing is putting collars on
and benching by yourself that's the
danger yeah interesting and it gets
stuck if the collars aren't for people
this is a safety message and a lot of
people don't realize this they think
it's safer to put collars on not if
you're benching because if it goes down
you can't get it up the colors aren't on
you can just tip it the weight goes off
otherwise it just sits in your diaphragm
and you can use to sink and if you say
like that guy in Jungle Book if you tip
it the bench is not usually high enough
to get out from underneath it yeah yeah
yeah I've had to do that before and just
do like a set up with like 315 I'm
rolling down on your hip just did it
once before I did that one time yeah I
had to roll it down it was a dumb idea
that is a horrible lighting that much I
just done so many reps that's burned
down I was gonna say sometimes I put too
much mayonnaise on my sandwich comes out
the other side and again yeah right same
exact seams yeah spikes in my case my
wife puts mayonnaise my sandwich yeah
you're doing marriage wrong how and she
doesn't even put the mayonnaise on the
sandwich you're sound like you're
talking through a tin key I got a I got
a different mind today his mic to Mister
twin sitter we do have a guest question
somebody help thank you here we go
Aloha Crowder and crew
this is Coby come from way out over in
Hawaii I just like to send my law to all
you guys and thank you all for to do my
question for you gentlemen and took you
tonight if she's there is a out here in
Hawaii I work at one of the largest
homeless service providers and it's a
part of my job I deal with a lot of uh a
lot of strife you know a lot of people
at their lowest point and uh it weighs
down on you spiritually mentally
physically and I know you folks
similarly have to deal with a lot of
stress and strengthen negativity coming
your way for you all do and uh I was
just hoping you all could share with us
some mom some things that you might do
to readjust yourself to recharge you
recharge your mana as we say out here in
Hawaii your power your inner strength
yeah both uh spiritually and mentally
especially just so bizarre to see a
clearly like Polynesian Samoan with a
Steelers many yeah so many sons to play
it for oh is it
anytime somebody from Hawaii ends up on
an NFL team like everybody just
celebrates that team they just come
inside huge fans of Alabama to attack of
Aloha and then Troy Polamalu was a
amazing
safety for this because Samoans want to
go to
Pittsburgh no I just want to make
millions it's like one of their people
made it in in this big sports league on
the mainland kind of thing so it's a big
deal
now um steel okay so he's what's the
ministry Polynesian and Samoan by the
way
well there's Polynesia is the larger
area and Samoa is part of Polynesia okay
so all Samoans are technically
Polynesian but not all Polynesians are
Samoans I mean I mean I guess but if you
were Samoan born in the United States
you'd be someone without being
Polynesian it's right I mean I wouldn't
try and draw any distinctions there you
didn't answer me Samoa though you are
Polynesian yeah okay but they wouldn't
consider themselves Polynesian American
if they're born say in Pittsburgh they
wouldn't to themselves Samoan yeah for
so yeah you would identify Simone it's
like saying you know do you consider
yourself American because you're from
America you would say you're you
specifically say you're American cuz
you're from the United States not just
if you're Canadian you wouldn't say well
I'm from North America so I considered
right right I think it's kind of like
what happened you know with Jews there's
there's a religion and there's also an
ethnicity right and so I think with
American we say Polynesians we're
talking about a race of people not
necessarily a geographic regions yeah I
mean I don't know Polynesians are race
or not but I mean Samoan I mean I think
the Simone Simone themselves identify
themselves as either a race slash
culture from with a long history as
opposed to being like just more broadly
if you go 30,000 feet up and say oh
everyone in Polynesia but there's all
these little different groups or islands
or cultures within that air are there
any Polynesians who don't look
terrifying like they could kill me know
that all of them whether they look it or
not could kill you they could let it
never be said that genetics don't factor
and I have never met a Samoan who didn't
have huge legs and was incredibly strong
big guys big guys Samoans yeah I only
knew one Samoan who was a friend of mine
he just always like this is just how it
is some people you know if they stop
training they go up in weight right
there some people they stop train they
go down and wait I've never met a Samoan
who was anything other than huge yeah
and listen I mean I mean people might
say that's racist but oh well as far as
no it's a bit one of the best fighters
ever we've got any Mark Hunt and he was
they call him the super Samoan but he's
in New Zealand
I think that that kind of fits right
yeah I know but I'm just saying it's
weird for Americans I don't know I don't
care about the rest of the world until
one of them competes on our team you
know for me I don't know about you guys
i recharge and I appreciate by the way
thank you for doing all the work that
you do with the homeless shelter and
what we deal with is different you know
people hate us what you deal with as far
as the strife is seeing the pain and
suffering of others yeah but we see that
too
but we're pretty fortunate that we have
a lot of supporters so we can kind of
focus on that or in my case I don't get
to read any of the comments because I've
been banned from them here in the just
don't read them Stephen they're like
it's not really okay yeah but for me I
know that I recharge alone like I don't
know about anyone else but I'm someone
I'm very much an introvert yeah and my
wife is that way too which is great
because my brother and his wife they
have to do everything together
where's my wife and I it was actually
just not that long ago we said hey I
just want to make sure I don't feel
guilty my wife is like I don't want to
feel guilty be like we can just live
like two single people for like four
hours she just likes to read with a book
yeah and that's not an interactive
activity but there are a lot of people I
mean Wade you're that way you read a
book I do like reading what so do you go
off on your own when you read typically
or just read in the living room usually
my wife and I just sit and like I read
on the couch she usually reads in like a
rocking chair that we have okay
yeah we read it together so you're
Benjamin Button because you must be 95
yeah I I don't you know I wish I could
sit there and read books a lot but I
don't read books as much anymore because
when I read it's usually news article or
someone or someone sends me a book that
I shouldn't read to prepare for this
show so if I do read books it's more so
kind of informative like a book right
now I'm reading through this book on the
history of cigars or a book on sort of
the history of coffee and its relation
to capitalism is pretty interesting that
counts that often like I used to be so
before YouTube before the internet I
mean I would read two or three books a
month my wife is a speed reader she must
read at least five books every single
month day Wow the same amount of books
so for me I spent a long time ila I get
into sort of these little I get almost a
borderline obsessive I become a maven of
things so like right now I've been
watching old fight videos old boxing
matches without the commentary because I
don't like
everyone thinks this about this fight so
let me watch it without commentary and
just through fresh eyes yeah and and
watching Li Michael man there's some
some fights that the decision but you
can just you turn on the commentary and
you realize I'm like oh and Muhammad Ali
is getting the best early bleeding out
his face I'm telling you telling his
corner cut off the gloves because he's
done so I've been doing that lately and
then sometimes often where I'll go
through a series so I tend to watch
things I know I've said this way I
realize that when when when hopper
passed it was like one of those things
that was so hard to deal with we're
watching a film is more powerful for me
than a drug like a good immersive film
gets my mind off of whatever is sort of
bothering me so I do that that that's
kind of my way to recharge and as far as
with my wife I'm good with quality time
I don't know bout you but I don't really
need to talk I talk so much all day
right that I don't really want to talk a
ton when I'm home I just want to be in
my wife's presence so being in her
presence but she can be reading and I
can be watching something is sort of how
I recharge I know it sounds really
boring but I guess too sometimes people
they have hobbies to help them recharge
me my hobbies are like Brazilian Jujitsu
or the gym like these are intense things
and my body can't take it so much so
when I'm done working or doing that it's
just as low intensity as possible and
it's usually watching something and
that's why I will rewatch here I've seen
Larry Sanders at least three times all
the way through Wow
same thing with Seinfeld I've probably
seen the edge at least ten times I don't
have a problem re watching that yeah me
either so I think that's something that
I've fallen into over the last years
watching more and more of the same stuff
that I've watched before because you're
right it does allow you to kind of
disconnect a little bit but before that
it was cycling and golf like I I chose
physical activities Golf is not that
strenuous obviously like you do get
tired by the end of it to a little
degree but swords we have to blow the
guys in the locker room yeah that's a
very just depends on how many geologists
you know when you finished so those were
great for me because you get its commits
so different from what you do and I
think that's what a lot of people try to
find is you read all the time for work
and so going home and reading more
probably isn't always sounding like a
lot of fun to you right yeah and
something that gets you away from the
norm and so for me going out into nature
instead of being in an office either on
the road in cycling or on the golf
course yeah it's nice it kind of lets
you relax a little bit get out of your
normal rhythm and just kind of recharge
well I find I recharge best to when I go
why I go up to a little lake house up
north and I just that's where I'm
outside a lot you know it might be
trying some wood I have not like I'll go
to my uncle's cidery and just help them
pick apples help them Nash apples make
the cider have a cigar be outside but
right I do that so much here because I
don't have it requires a day for me to
do that you know cars make those days do
you guys find this sometimes that when
you get on vacation you're so much more
tired like the first few days it takes a
while to get into that rhythm to come
down yeah yeah sometimes that will
happen will it take me a little while to
just and I realize that's what happens
after we do live streams at night I
don't know open to like 2 or 3 because
I've got to be down on and it's hard to
bring that down from from got a level of
the energy that goes in the tenseness
that you have to have during your body
you know in your body in your mind to be
on all the time we're talking to people
or like running things or whatever maybe
then when you get to vacation you're
like okay this time relax okay I'll
relax a little bit more right okay now
day three may be really relaxed yeah
yeah you know one thing about the
question the what I heard the question I
heard two different things there's the
what I would call the like mini escape
stuff right like man I just got to get
my mind off stuff I just want to clear
my mind maybe I'm reading maybe I'm
gonna watch a show that I like or a
movie I play video games sometimes or
read or watch TV any of the three of
those like video games I do my lawyer
plays video glass elute so there's a
different level and I think one of the
things that the the question asked about
is you know he's facing in his daily
life a lot of just down hearted
situations where people you just you're
really bummed for people for life and
for society yeah and and some of the
things you know a lot of folks will turn
to god they'll turn to their religious
communities or their church families
yeah I think a little bit of that though
is when you hang out with your own
family right like even if you're just
there in those moments we're reading
together those other things but finding
some other way to remember that life is
not just that small bad situation that
you're seeing yeah in a day out and you
hear this from other people who work in
hospitals especially in ones that are
state-funded they just see bad situation
after bad situation and they start to
think that this is all the world has to
offer rum and so taking outside of that
and that could be either be watching a
documentary about something you never
seen before about you know science or
travel or the world and remaining horses
minis or horrible industry
watch the document so cute I know dirty
money is that if they're not treated
cutely yeah that what that's about huh
yeah something no I think you're right
I'll say this you know sometimes people
say like oh god is love and things in
this sort of justjust abstract way but I
will say as far as recharging I don't
know about you but I've never feel
closer to God than in my prayer time
where I'm just being grateful yeah
that's always where I feel like I really
connect I feel like it's God going like
hey look look at this when I actually
when I actually just go through
gratitudes to the point where I know you
know you should do more than just
praying it being grateful but sometimes
I'll just sit for 20 minutes or 30
minutes to like thank you I'll just be
like simple thank you so much for not
even necessarily specific things
sometimes I'll go through specifics and
I'll do something like man thank you
yeah thank you because I realize what I
could have I could realize you know what
what my situation could be like or what
if I'd have turned left when I actually
turned right you know if i zigged when I
should have zagged right I think
gratitude really does put things in
perspective and I know that sounds like
a bumper sticker but I do think it's
something that people need to be mindful
of yeah and I think people a lot of
times going to your point bill you just
need a change of perspective no matter
how difficult your situation is you know
there are plenty of positive things
going on in your life you know you maybe
maybe your job is not the best in the
world but you probably have a roof over
your head or you have family no I know
specifically right I'm half amazed he's
not coming in here doing
sword-swallowing every morning you
haven't seen him doing you know but
people do to people people do need that
kind of uplifting especially if you are
you're volunteering in one of those
fields that just is emotionally draining
I worked at in prayer care and education
at one of the churches that I was at
previously and it wasn't anything like
volunteering and homeless shelters and
things like that but we did have a lot
of very serious very difficult
situations that we had to walk people
through and so occasionally you just
needed like you needed a break from that
like you can't just make your whole life
about that because like you said you
lose perspective on the beauty of the
world you lose perspective on how many
good people there are out there because
you see bad all the time yeah or how
many people are doing well because you
see people that are doing poorly so I
think getting outside of that and having
a church group that you can go to or be
a part of a faith is super important
because you're gonna find that they're
very easily it
super important I will say the four
people out there and then I want to go
to regin see what just to recharge and
we have to go for people out there who
aren't necessarily involved in a
community or let's say you're house
bound right now because you're
quarantined everyone can sit people talk
about Transcendental Meditation or doing
yoga none of it none of it will clear
your head and change your outlook as
much as just sitting and just I know we
say use the term doing gratitude just
sitting and thinking about what you're
grateful for yeah and for me like I'm
super boring outside of work because we
work such a high intensity job where I
really earned for the kind of normalcy
that a lot of people have like for me
nothing makes me happier than going home
having a beer I play some tug of war
with Betty listen to my wife and how her
day went and then she makes a wonderful
meal often or sometimes we order in and
I'll just watch like the latest episode
of Curb and that is to me yeah dad says
that's as good as it gets
I've gone to Hawaii I've gone to Europe
I've stated some of the nicest hotels in
the world not on my own dollar but
people other people pay for it nice foot
the bill and then I race I rate the hell
out many many brain you are every time
it's not any better yeah like that's
about as good as it gets for me our lake
house sitting there with my wife with my
dog with my family you know people like
I want to travel I don't with with that
so one quick point before we get to reg
which is notice that this the person who
asked the question is in Hawaii and how
many people write ill would say man if
only I could go on a vacation Hawaii or
I can only do this there's a little bit
of it that comes from the heart and you
got to find you know comes from the
inside right it's the circumstances are
there but a little bit contractor you
later start it Thanks it's like a Polar
Express you like them it's been a mu
it's but just remember that's what it is
so if yeah just because something you
think the grass is greener on the other
side sometimes you just got to work on
your own lawn I want you to do that in
court one time I want you to say I rest
my case your honor but if you keep me in
your heart
I'm never truly gone what might be wrong
I haven't already done
all right anyone all right reg how do
you research I mean that's the thing
about platitudes and cliches is that
there's truth to them that's why
sometimes yeah yeah I mean a lot of the
time actually I was thinking about my
wife she works in the pro-life industry
with counseling women on the sidewalk
outside as long as hell to it yeah his
wife is really strong for I mean for a
woman I do mean for a woman but for a
woman she's insanely strong so I
continue 315 to look but yeah so she
deals with a lot more difficult stuff
personality too by the way yeah yeah
yeah so but when you see she talks to
these women you know is that are you
going into like abort their children and
a lot of times you know when we talk
about pro-life things we think oh it's
about making this rational argument
about personhood but most of the women
will say to her yeah I know it's killing
my kid but this is my only option and
she's trying to provide other options
she yeah health care centers and things
like that but to see those women just go
in there the majority not success
stories you know not the story of
someone being saved or a life being
saved I think what helps her recharge is
you know going back and thinking on the
few times that she was successful and I
think that's that's that's what you've
got to go back to is realize there's a
ceiling to you can't save everybody it's
just impossible right and one of those
sort of a cliched stories that my wife
actually draws strength from is the the
classic one with the beach where there
are its starfish washed up and there's a
little kid throwing them back into the
ocean trying to save them before their -
the starfish yeah but I mean the way it
goes is some old guy comes up and says
hey you know you can't save all these
and the kid said but at least I save
some and I think at the end of the day
that's what you have to be okay with if
you are working in you know trying to
help people that just to focus on the
ones that you were able to help and you
know what I believe was a start Garrett
I want to well I'm sorry we can't have
you in on this one right now we'll have
you good you got to just jump in son you
gotta jump in he's too friendly he plays
video games he's a friendly McGarrett
we'll throw like I know what a black get
will throw down when the time comes yes
go back and watch that Ryder confronts
right tell you this like it almost
brought a tear to my eye my wife and I
were watching the rushes and we saw
Garrett like oh my gosh he's just he's
just a little jumping bean and waiting
for it never came I know
I love you I love here like a little
brother I mean he's like a little
brother to me
I'm not looking you in the face because
I don't want to cry I want you to cry
stop stop being a [ __ ] so one of the
toughest things I member that we had to
do was when we did that video in
Colorado which is kind of other point
right like James O'Keefe and I loved it
but he has like six months to release a
video we did this omits we pre-taped
shows that week I went to Colorado where
this woman was about to have an eighth
month but was it 34 weeks 34 36 34 36
weeks and she was going in to get an
abortion and we were all just struggling
so much because we wanted to stop her
but we also had to be true to what we
were doing which was exposing this
abortion clinic and exposing the kind of
abortions that go on so we had to think
can we stop her we probably can't at
this point because we would have been
breaking the law had we actually gone in
and tried to intercede and we said you
know what let's just keep praying about
it let's release this video and try and
stop all of the other potential
abortions from happening and then I will
say was a total god thing we found out
that she she couldn't go through with
the abortion and in large part because
of speaking with the women who went in
with us so and it could have gone either
way I'm not saying that God owed us that
but it was it was really hard it was
really hard I remember who was with us
that were you I was there remember we
were sitting here like what do we do we
know man knowing that that there was
somebody in there at such a late late
you know pregnancy thinking about doing
that thing and then luckily we had those
two girls and they were able to talk her
down yeah they were but they weren't you
know they didn't go in and say leave the
right but that was a tough one because
we said well maybe we can't it was a
kind of a flip of that reg recent maybe
we can't save this baby but we can you
know we know that millions of people
will see this and we can save thousands
of other babies and we were fortunate
enough where you know it's tougher
because that's a personal connection you
want to save that baby more because
you've met her you've heard her story
she had three other children and instead
you know God was a God was a smiling
down on us and none of them well I don't
know how many people didn't have
abortions but we know that lady didn't
so thank you so much we appreciate it
got a little serious carrots don't look
them till them looked me in the face and
only me in the face with your lifeless
eyes light with credit calm / asks send
in your topics and this is great this is
what is this non-political it's fun I
love having reg
we're going to do another one next Ash
Wednesday we'll see you tomorrow with
the live super stream let us begin our
quest to find no sound